[Music]
on this Saturday night turned away at
the end of their Journey
Canada closes irregular border crossings
surprising migrants it's a little bit of
smoke and mirrors here is the new border
deal with the U.S a human rights issue
China's long game it's kind of a
Playbook burn oh you're a friend of
China Chinese Canadians warn of
beijing's sophisticated strategy that
stretches beyond their community
why was his dad approved he got told not
to make contact with the assessor or the
provider again controversy and questions
over medically assisted dying I like it
because it is Canadian and Zellers is
back in business but is the lowest price
still the law
global national
for a Nasser
good evening to you and thanks for
joining us a big change today at the
Canada U.S border as the clock past
midnight it became official a new deal
to close a big loophole tens of
thousands of migrants had been using
unofficial border crossings to enter
this country and it meant they could
make Asylum claims now Canadian
authorities will be able to send them
back heartbroken as some spent months
even years trying to cross into Canada
Mike droulet on the rule change and why
immigration experts are concerned
Crossings will still happen but in a
more dangerous way
if the new sign wasn't enough to deter
refugees from entering Canada if you're
crossing here
RCMP officers provided verbal warnings
in multiple languages
those who didn't turn around were still
allowed in but while 24 hours earlier
they would have been considered Asylum
Seekers they're now being returned to
the U.S via another border crossing
that's good news to the ears of Quebec's
Premiere
who applauded Ottawa in Washington for
taking action forty thousand refugees
entered Canada via the dirt path at
roxham Road last year alone and Francois
Lego says Quebec social services are
stretched too thin I'm very happy the
issue is in the wording of the 2004 safe
Third Country agreement it allowed
Canada and the U.S to return Asylum
Seekers to the country they crossed over
from in Canada's case the U.S but only
if using a formal border crossing
getting caught at an unofficial Crossing
like rocksham Road or Emerson Manitoba
allowed individuals to remain in Canada
while waiting on their refugee claims
under the revised pact the entire 6400
kilometer border now becomes formal and
anyone who applies for Asylum within 14
days of Crossing will be turned back so
if you're a refugee and you're desperate
for protection you're going to cross and
remain undetected until after 14 days
have passed and of course you will
destroy any proof that you have
um that you entered when you did because
if you're caught within the 14 days
you're set back that she says could
create jobs for Smugglers and while
Canada has agreed to welcome an
additional 15 000 refugees on
humanitarian grounds immigration lawyers
worry it won't benefit those Crossing on
foot this idea of 15 000 is simply a
distraction and it uh it doesn't
mitigate what has happened now nor will
it likely deter refugees desperate to
get into the country microlight Global
News Toronto
the Border wasn't the only key issue
during the bilateral meetings in Ottawa
this week increased tension with China
it was also an important topic during
Biden's visit this especially as the
Trudeau government grapples with
allegations of beijing's political
interference for the West block Mercedes
Stevenson spoke with David Cohen he is
the U.S ambassador to Canada on standing
United against China's threats and she
joins me now from Ottawa Mercedes there
was a lot of discussion in those
speeches yesterday about defense
security and the economy and the war in
Ukraine but a lot of concern about China
too so what did the Ambassador tell you
about how prominently these
conversations were taking place behind
the scenes
well far as you said there was plenty of
direct criticism of Russia's ongoing war
against Ukraine Ambassador David Cohen
says that Joe Biden and Justin Trudeau
wanted to send a clear message to China
too pointing to the presence of the two
Michaels at President Biden's speech in
the House of Commons as not only a
powerful moment in history but also a
signal to Beijing
for me the emotional punch in the gut of
the Parliamentary speech was the two
Michaels and the comments that both the
Prime Minister and the president made
about that and about the leadership that
Canada has played with now 70 countries
attacking arbitrary detention all of
that was was China directed Canada and
the United States together are prepared
to take on China when China needs to be
taken on to protect ourselves from a
defense in a commercial capacity
and Mercedes you also have a panel of
Chinese Canadians on the show this week
chaquan is a pro-democracy Advocate and
Joanna Joanna Chu who's a reporter from
the Toronto Star and and part of what
you're talking about with them is how
significant and sophisticated the
Chinese government's influence and
interference schemes are so what can you
tell us about that
if our panelists say that the Chinese
Canadian Community has been warning
about beijing's influence and
interference for years and that China's
strategy to get What It Wants goes far
beyond the Chinese Canadian community
and there's frustration that Ottawa is
sort of only talking about this now
Chuck Quan warns that what is being
covered in the media right now is
basically the tip of the iceberg he says
it's less than 10 percent of what's
really going on behind the scenes
from the election of school board
trustees to Municipal Mayors and
councilors
to the provincial government and of
course the federal government so this is
something that I I think we should we
should be aware that we're not we're not
parking up the wrong tree
and pharah Joanna Chu is an
award-winning author who has written all
about China's strategies and she points
out that foreign interference and
influence can also take on a friendly
face and that can be just as Insidious
as it's targeted at businesses academics
Bay Street and Powerful Canadians it's
sophisticated and it can even be
Charming
Chinese Canadians are talking about how
their family friends are threatened if
they don't comply if they don't try to
cooperate with China but the current
approach I think is still a larger slice
of the pie of what China tries to do so
you know inviting even like pretty
low-level politicians city councilors of
smaller towns in Canada to these very
lavish VIP all expense pay trips in
China
and pharah Joanna says that that can be
used as a way to pressure people not to
criticize China on human rights records
and those strategies can bear fruit for
decades so a very long-term approach
will have more of all of that on the
show tomorrow I look forward to the
discussion Mercedes Stevenson and Ottawa
thank you Mercedes And as Mercedes
mentioned this important discussion will
be on the west block tomorrow right here
on global
and more than 25 people are dead after
powerful storms and at least one tornado
tore through the southern U.S overnight
homes have been reduced to toothpicks
and cars thrown around like toys it's
feared more people could be found dead
as Crews search for residents declared
missing believed to be trapped under the
rubble Global's Brittany Rosen has the
latest on the rescue efforts that are
underway right now
this is the wrath of a monstrous tornado
that descended on numerous rural towns
in Mississippi Friday night
it left an unusually lengthy path of
Destruction spanning roughly 160
kilometers uprooting trees Downing power
lines and severing homes and buildings
we had to tornado sirens going all
warning people to you know take cover it
happened so fast
well Mississippi was at the center of
the destruction the violent storm also
battered Southern States Alabama and
Tennessee tens of thousands were
reportedly still without power Saturday
it was coming right behind us because as
soon as we got in there we heard a big
boom at its climax golf ball-sized hail
and wind gusts of nearly 130 kilometers
per hour were reported it's unclear
exactly how many Twisters touched down
but the National Weather Service is
examining the possibility of a skipping
tornado which has a discontinuous damage
path
oh man
in its wake the storm left dozens
injured and more than 20 people dead
that was my nephew they got passed away
but it's the first storm they ever hit
some citizens I've been living hello
surgeon rescue Mississippi officials
brace for the death toll to rise as
Crews sort through piles of the wreckage
in heart attack communities like Rolling
Fork which has been plagued with
twisters for years at last count four
people were still missing I'm very
heavy-hearted at this time
you know um by the fact me and my uh
rather we was texting at the time when
the storm coming through and um and I
got to hear his last words and while
officials say the worst has passed the
grief and loss in these communities will
be felt for a very long time
Brittany Rose in Global News
an explosion at a chocolate factory in
Pennsylvania has left two people dead
and five others missing
a nearby weather camera captured
yesterday's blast in West reading about
100 kilometers Northwest of Philadelphia
today rescue workers are calming the
debris for survivors officials say
they've already found one person alive
the discovery of Life overnight of the
overnight recovery efforts provides hope
that others still may be found
the cause of the explosion hasn't been
determined yet but an initial incident
report points to a gas leak it's still
unclear how many people were inside the
building at the time but the company
employs about 850 people
more protests some turning violent in
France today this time over an
irrigation project in a rural region of
the country
[Music]
ah
thousands of Marchers opposing a planned
Reservoir that could limit water usage
based off with Riot police at a
construction site police fired tear gas
at some who threw fireworks and other
projectiles and some police cars went up
in Flames this latest violence comes
after unpopular pension reforms set up
waves of protests across France the
public angers so bad a planned visit by
King Charles next week has been
postponed
all right
[Music]
and thousands pack the streets of Tel
Aviv today to protest a Judicial
overhaul by the Israeli government prime
minister Benjamin netanyahu's plan gives
more control to politicians and
decreases the role of the Supreme Court
the plan is drawn International
criticism including from Top allies this
is the 12th week of demonstrations which
started in January after the reform
package was announced
the complex legal battle around
medically assisted death
coming up a British Columbia man who
says his father should not have been
eligible to end his life
medical assistance in dying or maid is
one of the fiercest legal debates
underway in Canada right now this month
it was supposed to be illegal for people
whose only condition is a mental illness
but the federal government delayed that
eligibility expansion for at least
another year as tariya isri reports it
comes after pressure from psychiatrists
Patient Advocates and families including
a BC man who says his father was
suicidal and still received a medically
assisted death
dad sitting across from me in the pub
Christopher Lyon's father received a
medically assisted death to this day he
doesn't know how he was approved you
should be able to have a very clear
understanding of what rationales or what
reasons were used to justify that and we
do not have those John Lyon was a
retired police officer he loved playing
the flute and lived on a boat off
Vancouver Island that's him in happier
times his son says his dad struggled
with depression and Suicidal Thoughts
two years ago he was sent to hospital
after a sepsis infection and multiple
Falls it was during this time around
there about he started thinking about he
mentioned maid not long after the 77
year old applied at Victoria's Royal
Jubilee Hospital and was granted
approval I was astounded at this and
sort of reiterated my concerns and and
got told not to make contact with the
assessor or with the provider again I
got there on a Thursday night and he
died on a Friday
but even after his death Christopher
says he received few answers from the
hospital the reasons that we were told
which related to stopping eating and
drinking and an infection they didn't
want treated aren't on that form so we
don't know why the health authority for
Vancouver Island
privacy concerns but Christopher Lyon is
speaking publicly he shared his story
with a parliamentary committee arguing
that if his father had better access to
housing and Health Care things may have
been different this government appears
to be inexorably moving from a culture
of life
to a culture of death it is not the
kinds of hypotheticals that are trotted
out uh oftentimes rather hyperbolically
about oh well someone who who has just
thought about
suicide or is feeling down will get I
that is it is not the case read the
guidelines under the law
irremediable mental health conditions
would qualify there is no
differentiation between mental illness
and other so-called physical or medical
conditions uh after all psychiatric
illness is a disorder of the human brain
but this psychiatrist warns there's no
consensus on which disorders never
improve I believe that some people have
already received a medically assisted
death for reasons that Society initially
would not have wanted them to it's not
the kind of death Christopher wanted for
his father if someone is suicidal and
they have an illness that they can use
to justify access to maid with
we end up in some very dangerous places
a debate about what it means to die on
your own terms
Global News Ottawa
a provincial first ahead the BC
agreement allowing an indigenous
Community to manage its own child
welfare program
foreign
British Columbia has become the first in
that Province to sign an agreement with
the federal government over its own
child welfare program the goal is to
reduce the number of indigenous children
in government Care by keeping them
within their own Community Victoria
Familia reports on this historic
agreement
it was a historic and emotional day for
the Splatoon first nation in the shoe
swap
thank you
splichin along with the federal and
provincial governments signed the first
ever coordination agreement in BC it's
aimed at protecting the well-being of
First Nations children and allowing the
indigenous Community to take charge of
its own child and family services and it
was celebrated during a ceremony in
Enderby we can't stress enough that it
does take a community to raise a child
and how how do we how do we
uh translate that into an effective
child welfare program because it cannot
be just based on the needs of the child
it's got to be based on the needs of
your community the agreement will
transfer
136.2 million dollars to splatine over
10 years to support their ongoing
delivery of child family services
through their culture and family systems
again restoring the care and the control
to the rightful people which is the
community with the appropriate fiscal
resources to be able to do that what I
can say is that the federal government
often has provided really bad guidance
for First Nations communities and so we
know that the expertise lies in
community
and we will continue to be there with
the tools that communities need
splitting has been exercising
jurisdiction and protecting children
under its own bylaw since 1980 and they
will continue this work but now with
more funding and tools under this new
agreement when you have a look at the
agreement you'll see that there are
Provisions in there for the province to
work alongside Splat scene and also to
be able to get out of the way so
whatever the nation needs and how
children need to be best served is where
the province is able to work in
Partnership former and current First
Nations leaders spoke about how
important this agreement is for their
communities and could be Doug Thomas
said this is especially crucial
following the residential schools
we suffered an identity crisis through
the residential school it'll it caused
addiction issues and that's the reason
why this program existed in the first
place in the 60 scoop existed in the
first place because
to take the Indian out of the child was
the main directive of these schools this
agreement is the fifth of its kind in
Canada and it's aimed at improving the
lives of First Nations children as well
as reducing the number of them in
government care Victoria Familia Global
News
[Music]
back after a decade next Zeller's big
bet on Nostalgia and if Shoppers are
flying into the hype
[Music]
Sydney's iconic Opera House went dark
today to Mark Earth hour all
non-essential lights in the Australian
city were turned off for an hour to
increase awareness about our ecological
footprint in Hong Kong a darkened
Skyline with nearly 4 000 companies
organizations and buildings also joined
the campaign more than seven thousand
cities around the world are expected to
participate showing a commitment to
protecting the planet from the impacts
of climate change
a number of Canadian Shoppers are now
getting hit hard by Nostalgia after
shutting down across Canada 10 years ago
Zeller has made a comeback this week
it's testing the waters with a dozen
pop-ups located within Hudson's Bay
department stores but the question
remains does the second act of this once
popular discount chain have staying
power and gaviola takes a look I used to
have ziller's back the first 12 of 25
Zellers locations opening their doors
this week in Ontario and Alberta I did a
lot of shopping in zealous for my kids
from my grandkids for this woman it's
like a homecoming I worked with zelos
for 25 years
the day is alert closed I retired the
highly branded pop-ups are occupying ten
thousand square feet inside HBC stores
selling items exclusive to Zellers from
clothing and toys to housewares hoping
to cash in on the Nostalgia factor that
remains long after Zeller's shut down
across Canada a decade ago
retail experts say there's an
opportunity for a discount retailer to
compete with Walmart Joe Fresh Ikea and
Dollarama as households deal with high
inflation and I couldn't wait to get
here I was like where's the closest
location Scarborough Town Center were
coming so we wanted to see what the good
deals are pretty excited it is exciting
because at least you guys have
affordable stuff that people can come
and get are you with zella's customer
unlike the original Zellers with its
slogan Where the lowest price is the law
this Resurrection is also targeting
mid-price shoppers but retail analysts
aren't optimistic about its staying
power after the initial hype dies down I
just don't see Nostalgia as being a
long-term sustainable competitive
Advantage for a retailer the only thing
that could help them if for some reason
it got hot you know like people it
became trendy to have a Zeller
sweatshirt there's definitely space for
another you know discount chain
um in my opinion
um I just don't know
if Zellers is that chain necessarily
with visits to malls on the decline much
of its future success hinges on its
ability to connect with consumers online
we dictate the way that we want to
consume more so today than we ever have
in the past
um and that's created some some
challenges for some businesses to kind
of innovate and and adapt and change to
another Zeller's Advantage I like it
because it is Canadian
high-end American Retailer Nordstrom
which is pulling out of the country
Zellers is homegrown and gaviola Global
News Toronto
and that's global national for this
Saturday night I'm Farah Nasser and on
behalf of our whole career I want to
thank you so much for spending part of
your evening with us tonight Sierra
Canada is this gorgeous bird's eye view
of Vancouver we love seeing your Canada
so please keep emailing us your photos
to viewers at globalnational.com until
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
take care of each other good night
thank you
[Music]